as greece gears up for tough talks with
the troika over a further 2 billion
euros worth of cuts the european
parliament was in athens to talk about
growth in the south the greek minister
for development underlined the pressing
priority crisis is fueling populism and
in our case the case of Greece a
neo-nazi party violence and even
terrorism though the eurozone recorded a
naught point three percent growth in GDP
in the second quarter after an 18-month
recession the recovery remains fragile
and 26 million people are out of work
growth of 1.5% is needed before people
can get back to work 0.5% the banks who
get the money for such an interest rate
from the central bank have to inject the
money in real economy and therefore we
need a created program for small and
middle enterprises who are creating most
of the new jobs EU decision makers agree
on the goals but not the means we need
to continue with austerity the
consolidation of the public finances but
at the same time we need to have
measures that creates the conditions for
gross we need at least three four five
leftist progressive European governments
to create a new Europe if we can do that
then the youngsters will go on facing
the problems they face today whether
through austerity or other means the
problems facing the South need to be
resolved or the same problems may be
replicated in the north